-Performing "Silver Tongues"
from his new album
"Faith in the Future,"
please welcome Louis Tomlinson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Gettin' high
on the amber wave ♪
♪ Going deep for the ones
who do the same ♪
♪ Air Maxes and silver tongues ♪
♪ Settle in
for another heavy one ♪
♪ You said love
was a pretty lie ♪
♪ I choked when your smoke
got in my eye ♪
♪ Bad logic and empty cans ♪
♪ I know nobody understands ♪
♪ Me like you do ♪
♪ You know, it's times like
these, we're so much happier ♪
♪ Nights like these, we'll
remember those stupid jokes ♪
♪ Only we know ♪
♪ You know, when I'm with you,
I'm so much happier ♪
♪ Nights like these, we'll
remember those songs we wrote ♪
♪ Only we know ♪
♪ You smile at me and say,
"It's time to go" ♪
♪ I don't feel like goin' home ♪
♪♪
♪ You said grass
was a dirty drug ♪
♪ You like to preach
with a vodka in your mug ♪
♪ I love all the things
you know ♪
♪ I'm king
on a fifty-meter road ♪
♪ We stand up tall
and beat our chests ♪
♪ We shout some things
that we'll regret ♪
♪ Sit down with a master plan ♪
♪ I know nobody understands ♪
♪ Me like you do ♪
♪ It's times like these,
we're so much happier ♪
♪ Nights like these, we'll
remember those stupid jokes ♪
♪ Only we know ♪
♪ You know, when I'm with you,
I'm so much happier ♪
♪ Nights like these, we'll
remember those songs we wrote ♪
♪ Only we know ♪
♪ You smile at me and say,
"It's time to go" ♪
♪ I don't feel like goin' home ♪
[ Instrumental break ]
♪♪
♪ You and me until the end ♪
♪ Wakin' up to start again ♪
♪ There's nowhere else
that I would rather be ♪
♪ Because it's times like these,
we're so much happier ♪
♪ Nights like these, we'll
remember those stupid jokes ♪
♪ Only we know ♪
♪ You know, when I'm with you,
I'm so much happier ♪
♪ Nights like these, we'll
remember those songs we wrote ♪
♪ Only we know ♪
♪ You smile at me and say,
"It's time to go" ♪
♪ I don't feel like goin' home ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!